Am Schluss dachte ich:
"Ich werde einfach sterben."w
Und ich hatte mich auch
seelisch darauf vorbereitet,
dass ich dort
gar nicht mehr rauskomme.
Die Psychiatrie war damals Stiefkind
der Medizin, der Gesellschaft,
sie war unterbemittelt,
wo man hingeschaut hat.
Die Versuche umfassten
relativ schnelle, kleine Versuche
an ein paar wenigen Patienten
bis hin
zu gross angelegten Versuchen,
bei denen mehrere Hundert Patienten
betroffen waren.
Was man in den Spitälern
oder im Gesundheitswesen
alles an Menschen getestet hat,
das war gar nie Thema.
Denn die Meinung war:
"Das ist zu ihrem Besten."
Ich weiss einfach, dass das Wort
"Münsterlingen Seeseite",
"Du musst auf Seeseite",
damit wurde man gehänselt.
Damit konnten sie mich ärgern.
Elisabeth Ravasio
zeigt ihrem Bruder Walter
die Psychiatrische Klinik
Münsterlingen.
Das war alles eingezäunt.
Aber kennst du es noch?
Ja, das Haus kenne ich schon.
Doch, doch, das kenne ich schon.
Hier wurde sie vor über 50 Jahren
eineinhalb Jahre lang
gegen ihren Willen interniert.
Sie war 15 Jahre alt.
Am 13. Dezember 1959
wurde sie in der Nacht eingeliefert -
vom Ehepaar, bei dem sie
ein Haushaltlehrjahr absolvierte.
Ich wurde von ein paar Ärzten
und Schwestern empfangen.
Als Nächstes sagten sie,
ich müsse hierbleiben,
sie könnten nichts anderes machen.
Die Krankenschwester
führte mich in ein riesiges Zimmer,
in ein Bett, wo ich dann
auch gleich festgebunden wurde.
Das hat mir fürchterlich
Eindruck gemacht.
Es hat mir eigentlich ...
Ich wusste gar nicht richtig,
wo ich war, mir wurde nichts gesagt.
Man sagte mir einfach: Spital.
Aber als ich festgebunden wurde,
realisierte ich,
dass ich irgendwo gelandet war,
wo ich sicher Schiss haben würde -
und das hatte ich auch.
Ja, die Einlieferung
war ein grosser Schock für mich.
Dahinter steckte eine unglückliche
Geschichte mit ihrer Lehrmeisterin,
sagt Elisabeth Ravasio heute.
Diese habe sie geplagt
und loswerden wollen.
Weisst du,
ich hatte ja nie die Möglichkeit,
selbst von einem Ort
zum anderen zu gehen.
Wenn ich vom A ...
Wenn irgendetwas war, ein Problem,
und ich wieder Schuld hatte,
Spritzen bekam und
im Rollstuhl weggeschoben wurde ...
Man war sowieso immer ein bisschen
benommen, schlief so halb.
Du hast gar nicht alles mitbekommen.
Elisabeth Ravasios Diagnose:
"Hochgradige Verstimmbarkeit",
"Neigung
zu hysterischen Mechanismen",
"intellektuelle Beschränktheit",
"Epilepsie".
Was hier berichtet wird,
ist für mich teils Horror,
teils falsch, teils suspekt,
teils oberflächlich.
Ich sehe meine Schwester
in diesen Berichten überhaupt nicht.
Meine Schwester kam hierher,
weil sie vielleicht
als pubertierendes Mädchen,
das Heimweh hatte,
sich nicht so benommen hatte,
wie es sich gehört hätte.
Aber man hätte mit diesem Mädchen
einfach reden müssen.
Sie kam hierher
und geriet hier in eine Mühle,
die sie irgendwie
total veränderte.
Elisabeth Ravasio
kam zu einer Zeit nach Münsterlingen,
als es üblich war,
Substanzen für neue Medikamente
an Patienten zu prüfen.
Von Anfang an, als ich ins A kam,
hiess es ...
Als ich reinkam, rief eine:
"Ha, noch ein Versuchskaninchen!"
Ich dachte mir dann: "Vielleicht
ist die nicht ganz dicht oder so."
Aber sie war eine nette Frau
im Alter von 40 Jahren.
Von dieser Frau erfuhr ich dann,
was sie bereits durchgemacht hatte,
und ich bekam natürlich Angst.
Die Medikamentenversuche
in der Heil- und Pflegeanstalt
lagen in seiner Zuständigkeit:
Roland Kuhn.
1939 kam er nach Münsterlingen -
jahrzehntelang als Oberarzt
und stellvertretender Direktor,
von 1970 bis 1980
leitete er die Klinik.
Hier verbrachte er sein Leben.
Er heiratete eine Psychiaterin
der Klinik, Verena Gebhart.
Beide erforschten und testeten
jahrelang Medikamente.
An über 300 Patienten der Klinik
testete Roland Kuhn
1956 den Wirkstoff Imipramin.
Die Pharmafirma Geigy
suchte eigentlich ein Mittel gegen
Wahnvorstellungen bei Schizophrenen.
Doch Roland Kuhn beobachtete,
dass der Wirkstoff stimmungs-
aufhellend bei Depressiven wirkt.
Seine Versuche
beschrieb er erstmals 1957.
Roland Kuhn ging als Entdecker der
antidepressiven Wirkung von Imipramin
in die Geschichte ein.
Ein Jahr später kam es unter
dem Namen Tofranil auf den Markt.
Psychiatrische Universitätsklinik
Burghölzli in Zürich.
Hier war
der heute 91-jährige Jules Angst
Professor für klinische Psychiatrie
und bis 1994 Forschungsdirektor.
Jules Angst führte als junger Arzt
eine Nachfolgestudie
zu Imipramin durch.
Die Herstellerfirma Geigy
kontaktierte damals
den Direktor des Burghölzli.
Dieser beauftragte Jules Angst
mit der Studie.
Es waren 150 Patienten
in der ersten Phase,
die für die Firma war.
100 kamen vom Burghölzli,
von der Klinik hier,
und 50 kamen von der Poliklinik.
Wie sind Sie bei dieser
Medikamentenprüfung vorgegangen?
Wenn der Patient
ins Aufnahmezimmer kam,
untersuchte man ihn natürlich.
Dann kam er auf die Abteilung.
Auf der Abteilung, oder unter
Umständen schon im Zimmer unten,
wurde entschieden,
was verabreicht würde.
Wenn man ihm
ein Antidepressivum verabreichte,
fragte man ihn natürlich,
ob man eine Pille geben dürfe.
Dann kam die Antwort:
"Ja, natürlich."
Die meisten
wollten ja behandelt werden.
Ganz selten nur wollte ein Patient
nicht behandelt werden.
Dann wurde erklärt,
dass das ein Antidepressivum sei,
ein neues Mittel, bei dem wir
gerne sehen wollten, wie es wirkt.
Man hat die Patienten immer
um ihre Einwilligung gebeten?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Das musste man vorher schon, bevor
es Medikamente wie Tofranil gab.
Bei Elektroschocks z.B. brauchte man
die Einwilligung des Patienten
oder von den Angehörigen, wenn er
sie nicht geben konnte. Schriftlich.
Und die Patienten in Münsterlingen -
wurden sie bei Medikamentenversuchen
gefragt und informiert?
Das untersucht eine Forschungsgruppe
im Auftrag des Kantons Thurgau
unter der Leitung von Marietta Meier.
Sechs Monate nach Beginn ihrer Arbeit
zeichnen sich Ende 2016
erste Erkenntnisse ab.
Wir haben heute die klare Vor-
stellung, dass es eine Grenze gibt.
Es gibt Grenzen
zwischen einer Substanz,
die in einem klinischen Versuch ist,
und zugelassenen Medikamenten,
die aus therapeutischen Zwecken
verabreicht werden.
Und was man schon jetzt
klar sagen kann
und was mich auch nicht erstaunt:
Diese Grenzen waren fliessend.
Um 6 Uhr morgens war Tagwacht.
Dann wuschen wir uns,
dann bekamen wir die Medizin.
Eine Handvoll Tabletten.
Ich fragte immer: "Wofür?"
Ich wollte sie nicht nehmen.
Sie hielten mir einfach die Nase zu
und ich musste die Tabletten nehmen.
Ich schluckte sie also.
Meistens waren am Morgen alle
noch ziemlich lustig und lebhaft.
Aber nach ein paar Stunden
sassen alle da wie ...
... vegetables.
Elisabeth Ravasio bekam während ihres
Klinikaufenthalts starke Medikamente.
Laut Akten war sie in Münsterlingen
offenbar keine Testperson.
Nebst zahlreichen Medikamenten
wurde sie auch mit einer
zehntägigen Schlafkur therapiert.
Heute weiss man, dass tiefer Schlaf
über mehrere Tage hinweg
gefährlich ist und
zu schweren Infektionen führen kann.
Wenn man sich
gegen die Spritzen wehrte,
dann waren die Schwestern stärker.
Sie hielten einen fest
und es wurde gespritzt.
Meistens wurde man dann in einen
Rollstuhl gesetzt und angeschnallt.
So wurde man dann
in eine andere Abteilung gebracht.
Und dann ...
Ich kann nicht sagen, wie lange.
Ich war vielleicht eine Woche,
zwei Wochen, drei Wochen dort
und bekam dauernd
Spritzen und Medizin.
Aber ich war auch im Bett
immer festgebunden. Fürchterlich!
Das war fürchterlich.
Was man dabei
körperlich durchmachte,
war grausam.
Das war wirklich ...
It was horrible.
Really, really horrible.
Zur Beruhigung von Patienten
wurden bis Ende der 1960er-Jahre
Methoden angewendet,
die heute undenkbar sind:
Hirnoperationen, Elektroschocks ohne
Betäubung, Insulin- und Schlafkuren.
Das Mildeste waren Opiumtropfen.
Oder dann gab man Schlafmittel,
Beruhigungsmittel,
und in schwereren Fällen, wie
gesagt, Elektroschock-Behandlung.
Ohne Narkose,
das gab es noch gar nicht.
Also nur der rohe Elektroschock,
der einen
epileptischen Anfall erzeugt.
Die Leute waren bewusstlos
und zuckten
und hatten auch Nebenwirkungen.
Vorher konnte man das
nicht medikamentös machen.
Opium konnte man
nicht dauernd geben,
und es wirkte nur vorübergehend.
Die Wirkung von Tofranil
hingegen blieb,
und man konnte sie
den Patienten ambulant verabreichen,
wenn sie entlassen wurden -
das konnte der Hausarzt machen.
Das hat zur Öffnung
der Psychiatrie beigetragen.
Tofranil gilt als erstes Mittel
gegen Depressionen:
ein Meilenstein
in der Geschichte der Psychiatrie.
Die 1950er-Jahre:
Es war die grosse Zeit
der Entdeckungen von Psychopharmaka.
Die neuen Stoffe,
die synthetisiert wurden,
machten die Pharmabranche
zu einer rasant wachsenden Industrie.
Mit Thorazine, einem Mittel
gegen Wahnvorstellungen,
erzielte der Hersteller 1955
schon im ersten Jahr
allein in den USA
einen Gewinn von fast 75 Mio. $.
Die neuen Medikamente veränderten
die Psychiatrie grundlegend.
Es war eine grosse
revolutionäre Veränderung
durch beide Gruppen von Medikamen-
ten: gegen schizophrene Störungen
und gegen depressive
und manische Störungen.
Die Beobachtung der antidepressiven
Wirkung von Imipramin
war der grösste Erfolg
der zahlreichen Medikamentenversuche
von Roland Kuhn.
Er arbeitete
mit vielen Pharmafirmen zusammen.
Die wichtigsten waren
Ciba, Sandoz und Geigy.
Allein für Geigy testete er
von 1953 bis 1958 neun Präparate.
Für Ciba etwa probierte Roland Kuhn
in Münsterlingen Serpasil aus:
1954 schrieb er der Firma,
dass es vorteilhaft sei,
dass er das Mittel seinen Patienten
ohne ihr Wissen abgeben könne.
Im Zusammenhang mit Imipramin
schrieb Roland Kuhn,
dass nur gross angelegte Versuche
erfolgversprechend seien.
Geben und nehmen:
Roland Kuhn testete neue Substanzen.
Im Gegenzug erhielt die Klinik
kostenlos Medikamente.
Ein Vorteil,
denn die Ausgaben für Medikamente
belasteten das Budget immer mehr.
In Münsterlingen
stiegen die Medikamentenkosten
von 1957 bis 1961
um das Eineinhalbfache.
Die Patienten
erzählten viel untereinander,
und es gingen viele Gerüchte
über den Mann um,
was er alles mit Patienten machte,
hauptsächlich
in der Männerabteilung.
All das hörte man.
Man hörte immer das Wort
"Versuchskaninchen".
Eine Frau, die ich in einer anderen
Abteilung kennengelernt hatte,
sprach gar nicht.
Sie sass nur da
und starrte vor sich hin.
Ich versuchte, mit ihr zu reden.
And she refused to eat.
Sie wollte auch nicht essen.
Jeden zweiten Tag steckten sie ihr
einen Schlauch in die Nase
und fütterten sie.
In einer anderen Abteilung
fragte ich:
"Hast du diese Frau
schon mal kennengelernt?"
"Ja, die arme Frau,
die musste schon so viel leiden."
Ich fragte, was passiert sei.
"Die war auch
ein Versuchskaninchen."
"Die vegetiert nur vor sich hin.
Die kommt nicht mehr raus."
"Du musst nicht um sie trauern."
Das habe ich oft gehört.
Dieses Wort "Versuchskaninchen".
Roland Kuhns Aufzeichnungen
werden seit Ende 2012
im Magazin des Staatsarchivs
des Kantons Thurgau aufbewahrt.
50 Laufmeter Nachlass:
5'000 Dossiers,
allein 203
zur Psychopharmaka-Forschung.
Hier in Frauenfeld
liegt das Lebenswerk
von Roland Kuhn
und seiner Frau Verena.
Im Nachlass
finden sich zahlreiche Hinweise
zur engen Zusammenarbeit
mit den Pharmafirmen.
Man muss sich das so vorstellen:
Einerseits gelangte häufig
die Pharmaindustrie
mit einer Prüfsubstanz an Kuhn -
aber natürlich auch
an andere Kliniken -
und fragte ihn, ob er
ein Präparat prüfen könnte.
Das war der eine Weg.
Und der andere Weg, den wir in
Münsterlingen auch gefunden haben,
war, dass Kuhn Vorschläge machte.
Er war chemisch sehr interessiert.
Er machte Vorschläge, wie man
eine Substanz noch verändern könnte.
Es gab einen engen Austausch
zwischen der Pharmafirma
und Roland Kuhn.
Die Historiker forschen
auch im Archiv von Novartis -
das Nachfolgeunternehmen
von Ciba, Geigy und Sandoz.
Bis zum Abschluss
der Forschungsarbeit
äussert sich der Pharmakonzern
nicht zu den Medikamentenversuchen.
Roland Kuhn:
Jahrzehntelang war er im Thurgau
und weit darüber hinaus geachtet.
Erst nach seinem Tod geriet er
wegen seiner Medikamentenversuche
ins Kreuzfeuer der Kritik.
Was jetzt aufgekommen ist,
könnte man wohl fast
Dämonisierung nennen.
Die Dämonisierung eines Arztes -
was wir aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht
auch problematisch finden.
Das führt zu einem
Schwarz-Weiss-Denken,
das stark polarisiert.
Die einen finden es abscheulich und
furchtbar, was dort passiert ist,
und konzentrieren sich dabei
sehr stark auf seine Person.
Die anderen fokussieren sich
auch stark auf seine Person,
sie sagen aber, dass er
grosse Leistungen erbracht habe,
sich auch immer sehr
um die Patienten gekümmert habe
und für die Klinik
alles gemacht habe.
Diese starke Polarisierung
spürt man jetzt.
Roland Kuhns Interessen gingen weit
über Psychopharmakologie hinaus.
Er hatte eine Seite -
das waren die klinischen Versuche.
Und gleichzeitig war er sehr stark
philosophisch interessiert.
Er war an der Daseinsanalyse
interessiert.
Er war Privatdozent,
Titularprofessor an der Uni Zürich
und er hat in Zürich gelehrt.
Er hat nicht
über Psychopharmakologie gelehrt,
sondern über Daseinsanalyse.
Die Daseinsanalyse -
eine Arbeitsmethode der Psychiatrie -
will psychisch kranke Menschen
in ihrer Ganzheit verstehen.
Sie interessierte Roland Kuhn
sein Leben lang.
Der Begründer der Daseinsanalyse,
Ludwig Binswanger,
war für Roland Kuhn
Freund und Lehrer.
Ludwig Binswanger
führte das Sanatorium Bellevue
im benachbarten Kreuzlingen.
Als Verfechter der Daseinsanalyse
weckte Roland Kuhn das Interesse
von Antonio Spilimbergo.
Der heute 80-Jährige lebt in Berlin,
wo er Chefarzt
einer Kinderklinik war.
1966 kam er als 28-jähriger
Assistenzarzt nach Münsterlingen.
Er war ja der berühmte Entdecker
von Tofranil.
Aber er war auch sehr bekannt
als Daseinsanalytiker.
Ich komme in Münsterlingen an
und die grosse Überraschung
ist Professor Kuhn.
Ich kannte Professoren
in Padua, in Wien und in Paris,
die wie Pfauen auftraten,
prunkhaft angezogen.
Und ich stehe vor einem Mann,
schmal,
mit einem abgewetzten Kittel,
Socken aus Wolle und Holzpantinen -
das war Professor Kuhn.
Er hat mich begrüsst und hat gesagt,
ich solle mich jetzt
um alte Frauen kümmern.
Das war im Haus C,
da waren Frauen
zwischen 70 und 90 Jahren.
Vielleicht 80 Frauen.
Und ich war
für diese 80 Frauen zuständig.
Hunderte Patienten,
viel zu wenig Ärzte und Pflegende:
Personalmangel war in Münsterlingen
jahrzehntelang ein Problem.
Die Klinik wurde
mit eiserner Hand geführt,
mit einer absoluten Disziplin,
einer fast übertriebenen Form
der Pünktlichkeit.
Ich möchte Ihnen
ein Beispiel nennen.
Professor Kuhn sagte mir einmal:
"Ich möchte mit Ihnen
diesen Fall besprechen."
"Kommen Sie zu mir um 10.15 Uhr."
Dann schaute er auf die Uhr
und sagte: "Nein, um 12.13 Uhr."
Jeden Mittwochabend lud Roland Kuhn
in Münsterlingen zu Kolloquien ein.
20 Uhr,
im Wohnzimmer von Professor Kuhn,
da sitzt eine Reihe von Assistenten,
aber auch Pfarrer und Studienräte,
und jetzt wird feierlich gefragt:
"Möchten Sie Pfefferminztee
oder Kamillentee haben?"
Das war die Alternative.
Und dann bekam man ein Gebäck
von der Grösse eines Eurostücks.
Wir verharrten in religiöser Stille,
in Erwartung dessen,
was der Professor sagen würde,
und haben den Tee
manchmal gar nicht ausgetrunken.
Da fühlte er sich wohl,
da blühte er auf.
Das spöttische Lächeln
und auch diese Strenge verschwanden,
wenn er über seine
philosophischen Forschungen sprach.
Während Antonio Spilimbergos Zeit
in Münsterlingen
wurden regelmässig
Medikamentenversuche durchgeführt.
Was haben Sie davon mitbekommen
auf Ihren Abteilungen?
Ich habe nichts, wirklich nichts
mitbekommen von diesen Versuchen.
Ich hatte zuerst geriatrische Fälle
und dann kam ich in ein Haus,
wo mittel- bis langliegende
Patientinnen waren,
die immer dieselben Medikamente
genommen haben.
Aber Experimente wurden mit
diesen Patientinnen nicht gemacht.
Wie erklären Sie sich,
dass Sie nichts von Medikamenten-
prüfungen mitbekommen haben?
Wissen Sie, erstens,
die Klinik war eine riesige Klinik.
Und dann glaube ich nicht,
wenn z.B. Professor Kuhn irgend-
welche Medikamente erprobt hat,
dass er das
den Assistenten mitgeteilt hat,
auch im Sinne
einer Beteiligung zur Entscheidung:
Erprobung oder Nicht-Erprobung?
Wie ist es möglich,
dass Roland Kuhns Mitarbeiter
in den 1960er-Jahren nichts
von Medikamentenversuchen mitbekamen?
Der Grund: "Therapie und Forschung
gingen ineinander über."
Zu diesem Schluss
kam bereits 2012 eine Historikerin.
Nicht nur in Münsterlingen wurden
Medikamente an Patienten getestet.
Auch am Burghölzli wurde geforscht,
ebenso in Basel.
Hier weiss man,
dass von 1953 bis 1980
insgesamt 60 Präparate
klinisch getestet wurden.
Im Jahr 1964 formulierte
der Weltärzteverband erstmals Regeln,
wie die klinische Prüfung
von Arzneimitteln zu erfolgen hat.
Die sog. Deklaration von Helsinki
legte fest, dass die Einwilligung
von mindestens einem Vertreter
einer psychisch erkrankten Person
eingeholt werden muss.
Sechs Jahre später
übernahm die Schweizerische Akademie
der Wissenschaften diese Regeln.
Die Historiker prüfen,
ob Roland Kuhn die Regeln befolgte
und Einwilligungen
bei Patienten oder Angehörigen
für seine Versuche einholte.
Nächstes Jahr
werden die Resultate publiziert.
Für Elisabeth Ravasio war der Alltag
in der Klinik schrecklich.
Vergeblich hoffte sie,
entlassen zu werden.
Das Waisenamt Bischofszell entschied,
dass sie bleiben musste -
gegen den Willen ihrer Eltern.
"Elisabeth Ravasio
hat bis zum Zeitpunkt,
da ärztlich gegen eine Entlassung
nichts mehr einzuwenden ist,
in der Heil- und Pflegeanstalt
Münsterlingen zu verbleiben."
Sie war so verzweifelt,
dass sie aus der Klinik floh.
Ohne Erfolg -
die Polizei brachte sie zurück.
Auf der Treppe
warteten zwei Krankenschwestern,
ihr Arzt und Roland Kuhn.
Kaum war ich aus dem Auto,
packten sie mich -
richtig grob -
und sie führten mich ins Badezimmer.
Sie sagten,
ich müsse mich nackt ausziehen.
Ich sagte: "Auf keinen Fall
vor den beiden Männern."
"Das sind beides Ärzte", sagten sie
und rissen mir die Kleider runter.
Die Badewanne war bereits gefüllt.
Sie steckten mich rein,
ich wollte nicht.
Ich habe mich so geschämt
vor den beiden Männern.
Auf jeden Fall
zwangen sie mich in die Wanne
und sie haben mich nicht gewaschen,
sondern geschrubbt
mit einer Fegebürste,
mit der man sonst den Boden putzt.
Sie fegten mich richtig durch, das
war so schmerzhaft, das war so grob,
ich dachte,
sie kratzen mir die Haut vom Körper.
Die eine sagte zu mir:
"Wir werden's dir zeigen,
dann machst du das nie mehr."
"Weisst du,
was für einen Ruf wir bekommen,
wenn das in die Zeitung kommt?"
"Wir bekommen einen furchtbaren Ruf,
das wollen wir nicht."
Ich habe natürlich nur geweint.
I was so completely ...
Ich war so ...
I gave up.
Ich sagte: "Gut, dann sollen sie
mit mir machen, was sie wollen."
I need to stop a minute.
(Lautsprecher)
The next station is Rayners Lane.
This is an all stations Metropolitan
Line train to Baker Street.
Elisabeth Ravasio lebt
seit vielen Jahrzehnten in London.
Im Sommer 1961,
nach eineinhalb Jahren,
wurde sie aus der Klinik entlassen.
Es war schwer für sie,
sich wieder im Leben zurechtzufinden.
Ich zitterte immer.
Wenn ich etwas mit dem Löffel ass -
die ganze Suppe ging daneben.
Ich konnte nicht aufhören
zu zittern.
Und nachts immer Schweissausbrüche.
Ich war morgens immer klatschnass.
Fürchterlich!
Und moodswings.
In einem Moment war ich happy, im
nächsten war ich nicht mehr happy.
Ich dachte,
die ganze Welt bricht zusammen.
Ich musste hart an mir arbeiten.
Sie fand Arbeit als Kindermädchen
bei der Familie
einer Holocaust-Überlebenden.
Eva Schloss überlebte Auschwitz
zusammen mit ihrer Mutter.
Die heute 89-Jährige erzählt
Studenten einer Londoner Uni,
wie sie Nationalsozialismus
und Krieg erlebte.
Wir mussten
einen gelben Stern tragen,
damit waren wir überall
als Juden erkenntlich.
Leute wurden auf der Strasse ver-
haftet und verschwanden für immer.
Vater und Bruder von Eva Schloss
wurden in Auschwitz ermordet.
1989 veröffentlichte sie
ihre Erinnerungen.
Heute ist Eva Schloss eine
international gefragte Referentin.
Immer an ihrer Seite:
Elisabeth Ravasio.
Eines Tages
stellte sich mir ein Mädchen vor.
Es war Anne Frank.
Nach dem Krieg heiratete ihre Mutter
den Vater von Anne Frank, Otto Frank.
Elisabeth Ravasio wurde Teil der
Familie und zog mit ihr nach London.
Eine andere Welt, würde ich sagen.
Ich fuhr mit Eva und den Kindern
von Basel nach London.
Die erste Nacht verbrachten wir
in einem Hotel, im White House,
next to Regent's Park.
Ich hatte ein Riesenzimmer.
Nicht nur ein Zimmer, eine Stube
und alles für mich allein.
Ich lief dort
fast die ganze Nacht rum
und blickte hinaus und dachte:
"Menschenskind,
das ist ja wunderbar, so etwas!"
Ich konnte gar nicht begreifen,
dass ich als einzelne Person ...
Why was that actually? Warum?
Ich weiss auch nicht.
- Zvi hatte das organisiert.
Jedenfalls, das war für mich
eine unglaubliche ...
Ein Schock eigentlich.
- Eigentlich ein Schock.
Sie kam aus einem kleinen Dorf
und war ganz überwältigt von London.
In der Nacht hörte ich
jeweils viel von ihrer Geschichte.
Das hat mich dann auch sehr -
ich kann nicht sagen beeindruckt -
aber es hat mich verstört,
dass so ein junges Mädchen
so viel mitgemacht hat.
Ich habe sie zu der Zeit
mehr als eine Tochter angesehen.
Jetzt ist sie
mehr wie eine Schwester.
Eva Schloss und Elisabeth Ravasio:
Beide Frauen erlebten Furchtbares,
beide schwiegen jahrzehntelang.
Eva Schloss brach ihr Schweigen
mit ihrer Autobiografie,
mehr als 40 Jahre nach dem Krieg.
Elisabeth Ravasio
redet heute zum ersten Mal
über ihre traumatische Zeit
in Münsterlingen,
über 50 Jahre später.
Ich habe manchmal,
wenn sie etwas erzählt hat, gedacht:
"Hei, das ist ja ganz ähnlich."
Als sie z.B. sagte, das niemand an
ihrer Geschichte interessiert war,
dachte ich,
dass es mir ähnlich ergangen war.
Wenn ich zu Hause
etwas erzählen wollte, hiess es:
"Sei doch still, das ist vorbei!
Das hat doch keinen Sinn."
Ich denke doch,
so war es in unserer Zeit.
Man hatte das psychologische Wissen
nicht, das man heute hat.
Man wusste nicht,
dass man darüber sprechen muss,
um es verarbeiten zu können.
Sommer 2017: Das Forschungsteam
ist seit einem Jahr an der Arbeit.
Die Dimensionen des Projekts
sind riesig.
Roland Kuhn
testete mehrere Dutzend Substanzen
über einen viel längeren Zeitraum
als erwartet.
Angesichts der vielen Quellen müssen
die Historiker stark fokussieren.
Wir haben uns sehr gut überlegt:
Was wird wichtig sein
für unsere Arbeit?
Und dann geht es für uns darum, dass
wir ein möglichst breites Spektrum
an unterschiedlichen Fällen haben.
Also z.B. Leute,
die sehr jung sind oder alt,
ambulante Patienten,
stationäre Patienten usw.
Alexander Dreher
war ein ambulanter Patient.
Versuch zu spüren,
wie es sich anfühlt,
wenn deine Arme und Beine
auf dem Boden ruhen.
Der heute 64-Jährige
wuchs als Zweitjüngster
von sieben Geschwistern auf.
Als Siebenjähriger kam er 1961
zur Abklärung nach Münsterlingen.
Ich fand mich okay.
Aber innerhalb meiner Familie -
mit recht fitten Geschwistern -
fiel ich auf, weil ich
ein bisschen verträumt war
und nicht die Leistung brachte,
die erwartet wurde.
Das veranlasste meine Eltern,
mich in der Psychiatrie
ambulant abklären zu lassen.
Im Thurgau gab es früher
keinen schulpsychologischen Dienst,
es gab eigentlich
nur die Psychiatrie.
Und das war dann der Weg,
dorthin zu gehen.
Das machte mich natürlich zu etwas
Besonderem bei den Geschwistern -
dass ich
nach Münsterlingen gehen musste.
Es gibt ja in Münsterlingen
das Kantonsspital
und es gibt die Seeseite.
Und wenn jemand auf die Seeseite
geht, Münsterlingen Seeseite -
damit haben sie mich
doch etwas gehänselt.
Alexander Dreher war 15 Jahre alt,
als ihn seine Mutter
erneut nach Münsterlingen brachte.
Seine behandelnde Ärztin
war Verena Kuhn.
Frau Kuhn - ich habe
kein Bild mehr vor mir von der Frau.
Nein.
Was mir geblieben ist, sind so ...
Ich habe ein Bild der Arztpraxis
mit Blick auf den See hinaus,
eine Lampe vor mir
und Elektroden auf dem Kopf.
Dieses Bild fand ich ganz speziell.
Das war irgendeine Abklärung
über Hirnströme.
Alexander Dreher
erhielt viele Pillen.
Aus seiner Akte geht hervor:
Die meisten waren
nicht zugelassene Substanzen.
Ich weiss,
dass ich niemandem erzählte,
dass ich Medikamente
aufgrund psychischer Defekte
oder was auch immer nahm.
Es war ein Tabu.
Darüber sprach ich nie.
Keto wurde nie zugelassen.
Alexander Dreher erhielt es trotzdem.
Hinter Ciba verbirgt sich
der Wirkstoff Maprotilin,
der erst 1972 zugelassen wurde.
Auch dieses Medikament
wurde Alexander Dreher verabreicht.
Er bekam es einfach so,
ohne Teil des gleichzeitig laufenden
Versuchs zu sein, wie es aussieht.
In der Publikation
"Depressive Zustände" von 1972
beschrieb Roland Kuhn seine
Versuchserfahrungen mit Maprotilin.
Verena Kuhn
schrieb in derselben Publikation
über ihre Versuche mit Kindern:
Alexander Dreher bekam haufenweise
nicht zugelassene Medikamente,
ohne dass er eng betreut wurde.
Die Substanzen wurden -
abgesehen von Pertofran,
dafür gab es ein Rezept -
den Eltern nach Hause geschickt,
damit sie sie
ihrem Kind verabreichen.
Alexander Drehers Eltern
wurden nicht darüber orientiert,
dass ihr Sohn zwei Jahre lang
Medikamente schluckte,
die zum grössten Teil
nicht zugelassen waren.
Nachträglich habe ich keine
negativen Gefühle dem gegenüber.
Ich finde es natürlich
nicht korrekt,
was v.a. meinen Eltern
gegenüber getan wurde,
die eigentlich Auskunft
hätten erhalten sollen.
Was geblieben ist, ist eher der
innere Konflikt mit meinen Eltern:
das mangelnde Vertrauen in mich,
dafür dieses grosse Vertrauen
in die Institution.
Das mit den Medikamenten
war für mich
eigentlich nie entscheidend.
Christa Thorner
ist eine Schwester Alexander Drehers.
Sie erinnert sich gut an die Zeit,
als ihr Bruder nicht zugelassene
Pillen schlucken musste
und sich niemand daran störte.
Eine Schwester,
die viele Jahre Hebamme war, sagte:
"Weisst du,
das war früher gar keine Ausnahme."
"Was man in den Spitälern
oder im Gesundheitswesen
alles an den Menschen testete,
das war gar nie ein Thema."
Man war der Meinung,
das sei zu ihrem Besten,
man teste da etwas für eine
Entwicklung, die gewünscht sei.
Und die ganzen
patientenrechtlichen Themen
waren noch gar nicht im Bewusstsein.
Patientenrechtliche Themen
ziehen sich als roter Faden
durch Christa Thorners Berufsleben.
Sie ist Mitglied der
kantonalen Psychiatriekommission.
Sie sitzt in der Stadtregierung
von Frauenfeld,
leitet das Departement
für Gesellschaft und Soziales.
Alles begann mit einem Besuch
der Psychiatrischen Klinik
vor gut 40 Jahren.
So richtig physisch wahrgenommen
und gesehen habe ich sie 1974,
als wir als Seminaristinnen und
Seminaristen im Fach Heilpädagogik
eine Exkursion in die Klinik
machten.
Wir wurden durch die Lokalitäten,
die Räume geführt
von Professor Kuhn,
und er stellte uns
einzelne Patienten vor.
Er sprach vor uns jungen Leuten
ganz frei über die Krankheitsbilder,
vor den Patienten.
Das waren grosse Säle,
die Patienten - Alte, Junge,
Drogenabhängige, Alterspatienten -
waren gemischt
und nicht beschäftigt.
Wir wurden durch die Säle geführt
und haben uns dann erkundigt,
was therapeutisch gemacht wird -
das war praktisch nichts.
Es waren elfeinhalb oder zwölf Ärzte
auf 700 Patienten.
(Originalton) Rund 700 Menschen
leben in der Abgeschiedenheit
von Münsterlingen.
Menschen, um die sich ausserhalb
der Klinik nur wenige kümmern.
Ihr Dasein ist freudlos
und die meisten wissen nicht,
wann und ob sie überhaupt die Klinik
je wieder verlassen können.
In den 1970er-Jahren wurde
erstmals Kritik an der Klinik laut.
Politische Vorstösse
beanstandeten die Zustände
sowie die Machtfülle von Roland Kuhn.
Professor Roland Kuhn,
der mächtige Mann der Klinik,
muss sich vom Interpellanten noch
weitere Vorwürfe gefallen lassen,
wobei seine fachliche Qualifikation
aber nicht angezweifelt wird.
Die Kritik zielt v.a.
auf den umfassenden Aufgabenkatalog
des Klinikleiters.
Professor Kuhn ist medizinischer
Direktor, Chef des Ambulatoriums,
Personalchef,
Gutachter, Universitätsdozent,
Autor
wissenschaftlicher Publikationen,
und bis vor Kurzem war er auch noch
Leiter der Krankenpflegeschule.
Ein derartiges Arbeitspensum,
bemerkt der Grossrat,
übersteigt die Möglichkeiten
des Direktors bei Weitem.
Man muss bedenken, dass der Direktor
zahlreiche Verantwortungen hat
und dass viele Fäden
bei ihm zusammenlaufen.
Das ist richtig,
aber auch notwendig,
und er delegiert auch viel,
sowohl an seine ärztlichen
Mitarbeiter als auch an die anderen.
In Bezug auf die Wissenschaft
gab es auch Einwände.
Es ist aber heutzutage so,
dass jemand
in einer psychiatrischen Klinik
den Kontakt mit der Wissenschaft
unbedingt aufrechterhalten muss,
sonst veraltet die Klinik
hoffnungslos.
Die Öffentlichkeit interessierte,
was in der Psychiatrischen Klinik
vor sich ging.
Immer mehr Fragen wurden gestellt.
Erste Hinweise auf
Medikamentenversuche tauchten auf.
Realisiert habe ich es
ein paar Jahre später,
als ich als junge Lehrerin
eine Schülerin hatte,
die wegen einer Schulreifeabklärung
in Münsterlingen behandelt wurde.
Die Schülerin ging
nach der Vergabe der Medikamente
bei Frau Professor Kuhn ...
Im Thurgau sagt man es so:
Sie ging auf wie ein Hefekuchen.
Sie nahm innerhalb von
zwei, drei Monaten mehrere Kilo zu
und wurde lethargisch.
Sie ass das Innere der Räbeliechtli,
sie ass fast manisch.
Und so fingen wir an,
uns dafür zu interessieren.
Ich tauschte mich
mit anderen Lehrerinnen aus,
und es wurde immer deutlicher,
dass viele Kinder und Schülerinnen
in Münsterlingen
medikamentös behandelt wurden.
Wir bekamen von einem
Psychologiestudenten den Hinweis,
dass Frau Professor Kuhn
in der Erforschung
von Testmedikamenten publizierte.
Das war 1975,
als das publiziert wurde,
oder schon früher.
1975, zwei Jahre nachdem erstmals
öffentlich Kritik an der Klinik
laut geworden war,
trat Albert Lingg eine Stelle
als Oberarzt in Münsterlingen an.
Sie haben überhaupt nicht mitbekommen
in den 70er-Jahren,
dass neue Substanzen
ausprobiert wurden?
In meinem Bereich
habe ich nichts mitbekommen.
Ich habe auch die vier Jahre,
die ich dort war,
weder von einem Patienten
noch von einem Mitarbeiter
jemals etwas gehört
in diese Richtung.
Albert Lingg wurde später
Direktor einer Vorarlberger Klinik.
Er schätzt und achtet
Roland Kuhn noch heute.
Bis zu Roland Kuhns Tod 2005
war er mit ihm befreundet.
Die Patientenrechte waren damals
natürlich sehr schlecht.
Gerade in der Schweiz
habe ich mich gewundert,
dass z.B.
auf Waisenamtsbeschluss hin
Leute ein Jahr lang
eingewiesen werden konnten,
und von einem Patientenanwalt oder
irgendeiner entsprechenden Aufsicht
war überhaupt nicht die Rede.
Die Patientenrechte waren
einfach nicht so im Bewusstsein.
Für mich war das Kriterium:
Hat es jemand
mit der Sache gut gemeint
oder wollte er nur, vielleicht,
sich mit der Pharmaindustrie
verbandeln und so weiter?
Und da muss ich sagen,
hatte ich bei Kuhn
gar keinen Verdacht.
Er wollte einfach etwas entdecken,
was den Menschen hilft.
Die Untersuchung des Nachlasses
wird zeigen,
ob Roland Kuhn seine Medikamenten-
versuche korrekt durchführte
oder die damaligen Regeln
missachtete.
Wie auch immer
die Antwort ausfallen wird,
Roland Kuhn war eine Persönlichkeit,
die starke Reaktionen auslöste -
bis heute.
Er ist eine schillernde
Persönlichkeit.
Es sind ja auch
unterschiedliche Facetten
von tatsächlicher Zugewandtheit,
die er auch hatte.
Und auch bei seinen Medikamenten-
versuchen gehe ich davon aus:
Er tat das in bestem Willen und
Wissen und wissenschaftlichem Geist.
Das sagt er ja selber:
"In Münsterlingen herrscht ein
besonderer wissenschaftlicher Geist
in der Behandlung der Menschen."
Und andererseits vegetierten
die Leute so vor sich hin,
ich kann nicht verstehen,
dass beides,
dass sowohl als auch möglich war.
Das ist das grosse Rätsel für mich
bis heute:
Wie kann jemand,
der so zugewandt ist,
der sich so
auf den Menschen fokussiert,
gleichzeitig solche Bedingungen
für die Menschen legitimieren?
Das ist und bleibt
das grosse Rätsel.
Ich habe mich gewehrt.
Und ein bisschen ist geblieben,
Gott sei Dank.
SWISS TXT / UT-Redaktion Zürich
Alexandra Duttweiler - 2018